Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie new legends of
tomorrow footage we have to talk about future
flash war reverse flash versus Barry Spear
of destiny.
So let's go there is a new round of the flash
ring giveaway going on.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a flash related comment on this
video be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything.
So there's a whole bunch of stuff going on
here.
We actually have some of the plot line from
the flash that spilling over, so try to explain
everything number six the legends is a massive
time quake in the 60s because of something
that.
The Legion of doom is doing.
They come back and they have this scene here
with it could find rip hunter.
But surprise surprise.
He doesn't know anything about what's going
on any as this crazy American accent I totally
love this and then you sort of have that funny
moment were he's like there's no such thing
as time travel time ships and then you get
the reveal of the time ship it actually looks
like he was getting ready to jump off the
top of that parking garage.
So the description reads is that he's like
this film.
Students so the big really funny about it.
So everything's gone crazy, but now rip hunter
is a big part of the story.
Again we kind of got teasers for him earlier
in the season and I almost forgot, it's moving
to Tuesday nights.
So that's gonna cause like a big shift in
my schedule.
The way I post videos between the flash and
legends of tomorrow and arrow.
So I'll try to explain what's going on next
week will be some more footage.
So don't worry I'll remind everyone what the
video schedules going to be number five though
the reason that he's back is because of the
Spear of destiny plot.
So when he knew at the beginning of the series
that things were going back the ship was going
down the set.
This plan motion and then hid himself in time
like everybody thought that he was dead is
just a society had no idea what was going
on, but because of the time drift he started
to forget who he was.
The Legion finds them and it seems like they
have some footage here.
They include those from the other trailer
were the reverse flash is interrogating him.
This looks like the scene where they mess
with his mind or give him a new identity the
reverse flash has all the coolest toys the
season toys for becoming other people toys
for getting information out of people so that's
probably just the beginning but the whole
reason for this is that they think that rip
hunter has the Spear of destiny or knows where
it is so that's why the Legion wants them
in their, also, teasing a little bit of the
reverse flash versus the Legion of doom, which
will talk about in the second but it's basically
evil slowly, turning on itself and I'm really
happy about this because it says a lot about
the reverse flash's plan his character so
number for the Spear of destiny.
You may remember the Spear from the Constantine
movie that was like a big Macguffin of that
movie, you know you tainted you gain the power
of a God, you could pretty much do almost
anything you want the reverse flash explains
to the Legion of doom that they can use it
to rewrite reality, so Barry can change reality
by going back changing the past, the best
way to explain it is that you have to imagine
stuff like flashpoint is changing reality
using big broad strokes like you change something
something stay the same using the Spear of
destiny is like rewriting reality with a fine
tip 10 you can make really minor edits without
affecting the timeline in a way that will
bring the time wraiths in the black flash,
so a lot of you do ask how come the reverse
flash is able to time travel so much without
having to worry about the time wraiths, he
just a lot smarter about the way he does it.
He has very special plans for the Spear of
destiny.
The Legion of doom, all have different reasons
for wanting it.
They all have different things that they want
to change about reality.
The reverse flash only cares about getting
rid of Barry Allen.
It's so beautiful very simple idea but very
hard in practice.
So will probably need to do a different video
that will explain that plan because you will
slowly learn more about it through the rest
of the season, but they're just a lot of hoops
that he has to jump through in order to get
rid of Barry without also getting rid of himself
because his destiny is so tied to Barry's
becoming the flash so he gets a little crazy.
But this is also where we start looping back
in the plot line on the flash TV show number
three future flash war.
So on the flash right now we got this tease
that something crazy is going to happen with
savitar is going to kill Iris Barry is going
to do anything he can to try and stop that
meaning that the message that they got from
future Barry from future flash on legends
of tomorrow is from a timeline where nothing
changed is like just the regular future for
what's happening on the flash right now but
something terrible happens Barry's like you
can't trust me, you can't trust anyone.
Everything has gone to hell, so the flash
TV show is all about changing that future,
so you have to imagine that right now Barry
is on a course to become like the blue future
flash in this sort of post-apocalyptic wasteland.
So there's this big war with savitar that
he's teasing is coming Barry has become the
future flash is really like the worst possible
scenario.
So what does that have to do with the reverse
flash in the Spear of destiny will the reverse
flash has a version of Gideon, so he's actually
been monitoring all the things that varies
been doing when he drops Barry off the beginning
of season three after he's killed his mother
again.
The reverse flash gives in that evil laugh
and says oh you'll find out.
So he knows exactly what's been happening
with savitar and all the stuff he just kinda
been trying to avoid it he does want to draw
too much attention to himself, the other big
thing this season number to the reverse flash
verse.
The Legion of doom, so while he's been trying
to stay off, of savitar's radar and watch
Barry try to spin his wheels trying to save
Iris.
He's also been trying to play the Legion of
doom, so I was so happy when the producers
talked about tension within the league about
how they'd start fighting each other.
So the be very true to eobard Thawne in the
comics he's not somebody that has friends
he's not someone that makes alliances he works
with other people.
The really most of his relationships are just
him moving ponds around on a chessboard like
he wants something he knows he needs a couple
other people to get it.
So that's what.
The Legion is to him just a couple of chess
pieces to move around again the Spear that
he can get rid of Barry the problem with that
is that Malcolm Merlin and Damien Darhk are
both really big villains in their own right
there not dumb.
They figure this out.
So part of the fun of the season is sort of
watching them unravel, but here's the main
reason why legends season two has been so
much better than season one number one it's
because it's more of a villain story it's
like evil goonies treasure hunt.
The Legion of doom is on a treasure hunt to
find the Spear of destiny.
Meaning that they will probably hold it in
their hand before it gets ripped out somehow.
So evil always turns on itself, but then it
all blows up in their faces in the best possible
way it is my sincere hope that season three.
They bring back the reverse flash and he read
forms.
The Legion of doom offering membership to
black siren.
I would like should be really great addition
to that evil team up because the villains
on the show are so much more important than
the heroes so as long as they got some solid
villains next season.
I feel like it will be great.
So there couple really big concepts that I
was talking about here like future flash war
Barry becoming the future flash of the comics
on the TV show because he's trying to save
Iris.
So there are any special flash videos the
you want me to do to explain concepts or storylines
just let me know in the comments congratulations
to the latest flash ring giveaway winner Larry
Irby just private message me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll just announce the winner the next
time I post a DC video.
There's a whole bunch of awesome stuff that
I'll be posting this weekend Star Wars episode
8 so new Legion some new Logan the Wolverine
movie and then sum game of thrones the be
plenty more stuff so just post updates as
I post new videos while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for Justice
league Green Lantern and you can click here
for marveled offenders thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight!